Tickle Me Tender man was so full podcast
was so full podcast welcome everybody to
the word so full podcast some of you
guys are barely logging in and all right
youtube.com for those of you who've just
made it out thank you very much man we
appreciate the love we got Rodrigo
Tori's right here we're know how cool
shirt
hello how you guys doing you're gonna
say no the cool shirt I think like in a
movie bro like that movie uh big trouble
little China on a little headband woody
we're not know he wearing a Hawaiian
t-shirt and in the other shirt sure like
that hell yeah I thought you're just
gonna be a little cool that's core
didn't come any a lot of courage bro a
big also we have Lisa Esparza right here
on the weirdest deal ever technical
engineer and we have raised Lipowski for
Chicago comedian extraordinaire you know
he didn't fill in we're gonna get to
know him he's not tough some war stories
we're gonna talk about Cubs
sorry Bears dolphins all right what's up
boo what was that bro what were you
gonna say that you did yesterday for the
first time oh hey we forgot
[Laughter]
shut up man you know be bad I guess
starstruck right where there's the old
legend comedian or anyone I like if it's
an old comedian and even know him but if
stays hello to me and I said no back I
feel like okay you and I can hang out
now I'm gonna follow you to the restroom
Aggies
cuz I'm a damn it again from si now who
the one I was there now he was uh the
bars in grandma's boy some sorta hiss
hiss is a boss in Grandma's Boy yeah the
boss he was he was in da Mosta
namaste Oh Kevin Nealon Kevin Nealon ah
from you say hello to me wrong so I say
hello to him too plus I was it I was
having to show with him so we get we're
I got to kick it with him ah
he was the first class never took my
seat by the restroom I'll yeah so dude
I'm walking around chillin had a long
weekend but other Vegas doing prayers
I'm at the airport and I see like this
healthy-looking man Rosa with a little
square face tan you know wearing a hat
just here nobody recognized him
I realized right away wrong the mustard
but I took a hit a mustache but to make
sure everyone here right welcome to
anybody and say what's up look at his
bag right there brought us the Oakland
A's
okay [ __ ] I'm going in that's it
what's up Ronnie fingers what our honor
oh my god oh yeah I can't believe this
you take it you to play with one of the
greats
when I was a little kid man like like
I've dropped the count much of you
school and you know that's not even all
these pictures bro catfish I don't quite
a blue blue with GI you know and you
were part of the aged man when you like
the good days when Reggie was there when
he was me good Reggie the module Reggie
Jackson Joe Rudi Joe Rudi bro has a Burt
campaneris
yeah and then that and then that do they
eat oh I used to I used to coach the
Houston Astros but then he play play for
the A's to forward or something Tom
forever got a name dan green dan gray
Tom gray I don't know yeah I forget his
name bro but he was you know old time
pictures right so that's what a selfie
with him bro and I said out man oh my
god
I really fingers you know greatest of
all time hall-of-famer [ __ ] are you
hipsters this is a real [ __ ] bus that
you [ __ ] posers
where anyways dogs it look I said Norris
and I got a little creepy afterwards
well your left
damn dude that's cool hell yeah he's
tall he's totally healthy break he could
here's a big-ass hat burly that bass
promotes a better call putting him
Rowley fingers yeah man there I call him
Joey COGO Diaz cuz I was supposed to do
his podcast but out [ __ ] [ __ ]
want you to do it we can [ __ ] that
tired would you be alive alive or what
when I get there we'll be luteum that
was terrible
yeah I mean you have eight flights to do
this week alone so recharge your
batteries you need to so Jody I went to
the baseball game with anybody Rob all
the kids from the for the class from the
school sixteen kids general mission and
we talked I got my baseball oh that's
what I'm talking about
older player bro the more the Red
Machine oh yeah Sparky I understand Joe
Morgan or Dave concepción yep Johnny
Bench Griffey kangaroo Foster Foster
with the bit with that but black bat
50-ounce bat they say had the heaviest
bat outside of our Babe Ruth damn dude
yeah they say that bat was heavy and I'm
back none of those pick those hitters
for the Reds we're home run hitters bro
they were just punching and hitting
doubles and triples knocking over I'm
[ __ ] up back hatches scoring runs
here's one you Cesar Geronimo yeah late
for them those are the guys were playing
when you guys were little kids yeah so
for Latino people hi we were kids huh
more black people yeah there was a time
bro and like I saw the documentary when
everyone in like the Pirates were
playing another team and and they
stopped to notice that in the first time
Major League Baseball it was all black
people on the field
pirates had a lot of black players loved
Dave Parker Dave Parker Willie Stargell
that guy who ranked Tavares d-ii because
of the socialista come on I was in
Stargell yeah there's a move that's a
there's a there's a Netflix movie about
him on Netflix great
dock at its dock there it is that will
stay to the asset tab yeah but it was so
good because I mean the thing is though
you know LSD I mean it's in addition to
tripping like you can become hyper
focused with it you know it does it
small doses micro dosing can help you
beat his ass it was so good maybe her
control then I saw the strike zone bro
it was clear she was elaborating and I
was like what she's really breaking this
there's micro dosing there she goes I've
been looking into micro see a lot lately
just interested in it because it helps
with depression and stuff like that but
also will you put it on my food micro
dosing for mushrooms and things like
that because you can become more
productive there's no tripping there's
no there are no hallucinogenic effects
when you do micro dosing when you do
small small doses but you have to
experiment with what a small dose is for
you you know your body was with me my
daughter brought me home some chocolate
from you know one of those uh reaching
oh yeah cupcakes today yeah she she
brought me over some chocolate and I
took a piece and that's she's like how
was I didn't do anything maybe you need
to take a bigger piece of chocolate so
the next day I'm sitting on the couch
and it took a bigger piece like almost
half the bar I couldn't move I was like
comatose I was like that like a mummy
man remote right there I'm stuck
whatever was on I watched everybody's
different though dude you got to find
your own happy medium yeah I was I was
gone I had a little cabin Sam and I woke
up feeling great Oh mushrooms yeah Oh
Mickey shrim says everybody should take
LSD that's his recommendation
about LSD is some people are some people
can go crazy and never come back
well that's what people already crazy
but this yep they're the thing is if you
are as good as you're predisposed to
things like schizophrenia a lot of
people have that thing that I don't know
and then because we know what dude that
like smoking p-dogs
and after that that fool just started
doing karate kicks never went back to
school and then start kicking it just be
standing there at the corner and the
bike by the bus stop with nunchucks well
I think this we're having a Syd Barrett
from Pink Floyd - he supposedly drank a
bunch of liquid acid you know and just
never came back and I had a Japanese
friend I used to come to the hood and
and it was Dean and he had a brother
named Phil I don't have a real name was
Phil but no David or James I don't know
regardless he had a name a food took off
man enough on the acid trip from what I
hear you know from those guys the older
the older guys and he never came back
he came back but not all the way that he
goes comes and goes and I when I was
living over there and I'm at water I
used to see him at that um Silver Lake
mental hospital right there way but he
used to live your ex-husband Ike
so I told him chillin right there but he
never came back
so he's like institutionalized all he
wanted was a Pepsi and that fully used
to work with this at la Cucaracha
he said he smoked P dogs when he was
like 13 3 balls ya know not be PCP and
uh I don't think there's always a little
hey Tommy come here dude huh like always
a good two or three he's faking that
[ __ ] bro do not work yeah like Ryder fix
you know there's something there's a
little screw loose in there dog
well what enough - pest exterminators
right dude that was 17 times PCP is
different that's different than LSD
way different yeah there's that'll [ __ ]
your brain up man disappear an elephant
scared to try anything anything like
mint Lenny bias we'd sit like Lenny bias
like they say first time you ever did
cocaine and he died well I wouldn't want
to be that Celtic player yeah yeah yeah
good pure [ __ ] yeah either that or he
wasn't his first time I mean I don't
know it wasn't the first time yeah but
you can have a hard it to anybody can
have a heart attack any time but his
heart beat your refasten either were
there running around could happen sooner
or later yeah you do crack like not
posed to run around Roberta you do crack
you chill you chill man and then when
you're done you rip the carpet out of
the hotel room and look for crack under
there and that's when you know you're
done when you started to realize you're
ripping the carpet or the hotel room
would you stop and you go get more crazy
money my bucket but you don't go on a
mission Manning or go play baseball or
do activities you run around the park
you mutt well you couldn't do crack you
back to the jogging in place you ran
around the parking lot down on Main
Street when you let you still live down
at the loft second it means what chasing
musical dilution was to lose ten pounds
and what I mean and you ran around the
parking lot like full speed afterward
could I do
I don't know but then I was like I'm
just gonna go home cuz this is not my
scene and I stayed then I picked you up
the next day and it wasn't your mess
yeah it was bad bad times that was those
bad times 2008 - those old where you
don't even think about it because you'll
get hard
I'm tired thinking about it
running around the building skedaddle
hey don't but don't be back in the day
when people using cocaine to go dance
all night now that [ __ ] doesn't then
they they mix it with alcohol it can
impact I'll do those right to know they
say that with what a boner and all of
that stuff and last you last all night
so I was going around the buildings oh
no we're on the parking lot okay
so square dancing yes what's up fool
we made ray lapowski and Chicago back in
2000 with two or three days that Club
riddles rid of riddles yeah that place
provided everything for us but the cash
no we got paid that it was cool with me
it took care of like anything we wanted
Lee God Rodrigo say I want a haircut
they send up his homie Sam to cut it
yeah he got a haircut a bathroom in
hotel all brothers club went above and
beyond and I think people truly thought
like are really respected the club and
and just the people the environment it
was one of the best clubs in a country
to do at the time I was got paid and
even when when like there was a problem
I want time two weeks before the show he
told me that the kitchens broken and
they're gonna do some renovation or
whatever
my cancel your date but I'll get you
later I was cool whatever where is this
riddles it was well cool let's do wasn't
brand brand Florence yeah she cuddled to
the max
Orland Park you know what I heard about
him I don't want to misquote but I'm Sam
Sam said that Michael pens right he's
the vice president right in Indiana in
Indiana now writes where he that's where
I'm Brandon probably live now so they've
been like trying to talk to him to maybe
run bro getting the politics get into
politics because he had a fan base and
he's Latino
and he's Republican so you never know
brand new floor is 2020 so Mikey o
should do Oh
knows every everybody you know Rahm
Emanuel Rahm Emmanuel's not running for
re-election next know I think Mikey
could put a stop to all that stuff
what are you Mikey oh wow
you thought you got go yeah you little
Mikey Oquendo man working wooden forever
years we read sure you do I have no idea
cago i have no idea give me some Mikey
Oh bro I can't even do my Gil he's got a
little Chicago in him a little little
Puerto Rican sometimes little he's got a
weird mix no he's what are you like
hardcore book Willy one time with Alfa
Robles oh yeah it's great great smells
great little very handsome 300 400
people but it's a nice intimate venue
it'd be great spotted like shoot a
little special like DVD yourself it's
pretty high up though I don't know what
the acoustics are like like if you were
recording it yeah yeah and then Mike
you're better food here the character
bro like like I didn't like my
microbrews like Frankie yo knees huh
he's got like a grandma sort of Puerto
Rican grandmother character that he does
sometimes he dresses up like her and
shows up on Facebook it's weird the
baseball toenail I forget her name it's
like Belinda something you've done that
you don't do characters where did you
story I started in Chicago we laid a
long time ago 20 years ago in nineteen I
how did it start I was in my car leaving
the post office you're a postman yeah
just work at those days and I heard a
contest on a radio and so I went to and
I had an Armani suit on because I was a
supervisor and it was on the south side
of Chicago where I never would go I know
those supervisors wear Armani
I don't know yeah I did I literally had
an Armani suit I'm office when I do it
works off the racket was and this is
back in what 99 so off-the-rack it was
like maybe 2 grand and my dad would be
like Patel you buying a suit like that
for or suits like that and I was like
what do you mean he's like oh I'm like
you could again for suits law or maybe 5
or 10
Goodfellas no suit fellas but so I heard
about this contest I went to it never
told the joke in my life it was the
longest-running comedy contest in the
country at the time was called the
Miller Genuine Draft comedy search I
ended up taking third place and
everybody was like who the hell is this
white dude who is this dude but the way
that it's one exactly he did your time
in your suit you went up once they don't
refer that for the audition I did okay
and then no but for the for the rest of
it I still like your stuff but and you
know it's weird you know and I felt
weird about when I saw you on airplane
when we when we ran into each other and
see I was like damn I when I was driving
up here I'm like damn I had to sweat
shirt on when I ran into Felipe so you'd
never told a joke in your life never
told how much time did you do we had to
do three to five and inferred it for the
competition what did you do you just
went up and started talking right I
started talking about this I started
talking about this one Chicago comic
because he was the only person that I
had recognized I saw him on Def Jam so I
talked about him and he hated it and he
was like he'll never work in comedy like
you know I'm gonna blackball this dude
what yeah like hated me because I did it
like I did a gay joke about him Oh like
he would like I was gay and he was gay
and like that I was with him you know
the night before so did the place went
crazy and you know
[ __ ] is this white dude this dude is
nuts and you know so 19 years later yeah
I mean for like a fur for a good like
nine-year run I was doing everything I
was on every TV stand-up show that there
was when you first started
no oh let's see
well actually like two years in I
started you know from the comic views I
did you know like four seasons of comic
view
you know Comedy Central HBO Showtime I
was on everything and people were saying
are ray Lipowski what did next comedians
to blow up and I'm like I know it
doesn't happen yeah so but when I was in
when I first started like a year and a
half in I know 1996 I got a TV show
Showtime Latino laughs first of all and
then they every year for three years
they put there myself so every year and
then after that was done the same
producer started on another show so I
got to every time this producer went to
a show Jeff out this he'll put me in a
show same thing with you right yeah your
your friend with a guy who started Def
Jam yeah
now you cuz I remember you and I we did
that show JB Smoove yeah I'm horrible
I know I saw ray he looked defeated man
like tired like he must have flown out
Chicago on a red-eye he landed at noon
we're taping that at 5:00 and he showed
up with his bags he has to the PA person
in his face and yelling at him know
you're gonna get ready for though
because they wanted to get ready for the
stand-in and F we just they're like
quiet after she what he waited for her
to be done I'm gonna take a shower to
the nap and I'll see you later
[Laughter]
I was sad to do that they're fully
kicked me out I heard a bicycle but now
sometimes people don't realize like what
goes into like even taping somebody's TV
show please don't no no no you've been
now you know the routine tell us about
the routine
well sometimes again like like for
instance like the comic view one of the
comedy seasons that I was taping the
Rica's you know from my now from my from
my season before just off how like
the the reception that I got from it and
like the emails and the right ends and
what not to be T about again how well
the performance was the following year I
had like the best spot on the taping of
a show and then George Lopez ends up
coming in and they're like you know ray
we're gonna have to bump you and I'm
like I didn't mind I'm of course I have
to take a back seat to George Lopez this
is George Lopez you know he's got his TV
show and I'm like yeah they're like they
were looking at me like you're not gonna
take a back seat to George Lopez I'm
like of course I will but why do I gotta
take the face like bump somebody else
off this show because I got like the
Primo spot in this taping 9:25 so I had
a freaking dude of like the one o'clock
in the morning taping oh but the
audience know the audience had been
there already for five hours and because
they thought that there was gonna be a
new audience for the last show there was
no audience there was nobody outside so
the audience that was already there they
asked they kept begging them people to
stay so now they already had been there
for five hours now they got to sit for
another two for this last taping at a TV
show maybe 200 people stayed out of like
the thousand and so it's 200 people in a
thousand cedar so it's empty you got the
200 people sitting up front so they're
only panning in under 200 people
obviously and I'm the first comic that's
got to go out and I was like it was oh
my goodness was it awful that when I say
I bombed like oh my goodness them people
were just looking at us like everybody
bombed on that show these oh no you know
what I think that back the only one who
didn't bomb was Lisa Lampanelli
she went out and for what everybody
murdered that thing like what the hell
and she was Lisa Lampanelli I know she's
still like this but she was like really
what's the word I'm looking for like Lou
well no name but like in terms of where
she she always feels like she doesn't do
well so she's like she has to I'm not
saying that she's looking for acceptance
or for like oh no no you did great
I'm not saying that that's what she's
looking for but she never thinks that
she does well like she literally came
backstage and she was like so nervous
and like you know scared and she was
like you know how did I do how did I do
like what like you just murdered this
thing we all bombed so it's you know
people don't realize like sometimes
those type of things affect your set as
well and what you have to deal with but
oh well did they end up hearing that I
don't think weird I know Lisa did I
don't think I I think that's crazy
that's like when you did the Miami South
Beach thing with Cheech and there was no
audience because you guys were taping at
11:00 a.m. they were going out on the
street
right they were going out to like pull
the audience in off the sidewalk like
they come in right she's just hosting
you El Madrigal ten nothing we Bank 40
to come in people are show bro with
grocery bags groceries bro like uber
let's go go a man a good SQL I don't
know who else
hey man we're having a comedy show later
that and it do it yeah I want to cause
nothing all right
we went abroad like your bag was how
embarrassing it was because Cheech
marine was hosting like he had been on
anything before that like a comedy show
and nobody showed up like and it was it
was it was during the south side the
South Beach Comedy Festival but we were
like on the side of the sauce you know
the stop sign at the main show bah bah
blah we were like in a project sign you
know we're like I yo jobra
we were in LA we were lettuce cheap
cheap side row nobody showed in the
daytime the day that she saw three
o'clock those tapings suck - we got
those early ones and our magic girls on
the show a [ __ ] menace bomb human
rescue boy had to do warm up Alice it
really did for the same audience yeah
bro that that's a minus 50 yeah so go
after that show me and Carlos Oscar Joey
Medina went to this bar and I pretended
I like wine brought so I got drunk a
free wine everybody knows by before
drinking slow bro talk
he called us to talk eat my glass was
empty category I think some good wine
but miss wine bro but you know what you
wife
white leads to alcohol will leads back
to [ __ ] rip your corporate software I
remember that one time you're like oh I
think I'll just stick to wine now and
that's like how long is this gonna take
before it's better
Roberto ladies and gentlemen we have ray
lapowski here the only guy who's happy
that Cali Mac went to the Bears
yeah I'm happy about that I saw Felipe
posted on Instagram he's like if Matt
goes to the Bears he's like I'm done
being a Raiders fan we're still gonna be
friends that will we be cool to be fair
you shared Manny's post yes you weren't
really saying you know the press for
that show in Las Vegas and everybody
will Kristen since the Red Hook moved to
Las Vegas everyone asked me about many
Maldonado's pose but they thought I pull
through and I was you know I did I
didn't notice that I was on TV bars to
see repost I told a kind of Fox News I
said listen that was a repost from Manny
Maldonado and who lives in Modesto who
the diehard Raiders fan it wasn't a
repost in it and I asked people what you
think
yeah so everybody turn around me wanted
to kill me by Felipe by Felipe unfollow
so so how do you feel about the Raiders
trading mechanism it man I've been
obsessed in the radio went back to
Oakland when I went to look when they
went to Las Vegas that's closer to my
house we're ready man we raised him and
broadly or Barstow
people brought up a good point though I
mean I'm having with them going to Vegas
but like your average Joe who goes to a
game now they've got to get a hotel
they've
a lot pricier ticket you know higher
priced ticket higher price weekend to
just go to that game now you know what
that'll keep the people that start
fights away from me
anybody who anybody who's friends with
Birdman won't be there anybody who
drinks
cheap beer won't be there you know like
oh there you go don't piss off Henderson
Henderson is Henderson in Nevada is
where all the cholos and gangbangers
from LA and Southern California go to
retire bro you know third a new life
could it going because we punk
Christians bro or you know really like
change your life but Henry says gangster
now a victory I started off with all the
other cribs all the Bloods and other
meskhi started moving out of our later
Reno to Reno doing the racial riots you
know the race fights between blacks and
Mexicans in the 1990s they moved to
Moreno Valley and what in Moreno Valley
turn into midnight at noon it turned it
to more Negro Valley no not your phrase
black comedian tested while cooking good
man
you just call you know the rap song
Brandeis okay Stuart Cheers there you go
Jesus any people I do I do a joke when I
like if you do like performing in New
York you know your novels and one time I
was performing in Harlem I might have
been at the Apollo and predominately
predominately black audience so I was
like do you guys like that you know some
white people now are moving in and you
know the gentrification and all that
stuff and then they're like hell no I
was like well now you know how we felt
when you guys started is the old reverse
please joke but people you know what
that's a great job but you know what are
you if you were to say that now or post
that they only see the first part all
right don't worry the first part and app
that first part will trigger them so
much that they won't even have time to
laugh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] laughing that
pisses me off now it is people are so
hurt I stopped thinking and you know
people are so hurt and this comedian
that we know that I'm the do like the
crowds you know there are the more
accepting of the word Calista comedian
component I'm off I was dirty
your friend he could be offensive but
but his audience his his fan base love
that dude yeah but you put that for he
ever hear a truth - joke one of his
jokes and then somebody was a lot of
followers reposted it forget about it
man people gonna cry because like he
said they're only looking at the first
part of it they don't see the whole
thing the same thing like when I do a
joke again if it's a like a black
audience or more of a black audience
when I talk about February and I'm like
you know I want to speak on behalf of
all white people we can't wait for this
month to be over and they immediately
get all offended and get mad and I'm
like let me finish before you know you
get all your panties in damn bunch and
he's like f you [ __ ] cracker all of
this [ __ ] and I'm like dude let me
finish I said were you not I'm gonna
show you my intellect I said well you're
not just as proud to be black in January
what about when March first comes are
you no not still just as proud to be
black I said what I'm saying it's black
history's not 28 days it's 365 days just
like all history is I said look at the
Hispanic people look at Mexicans you're
bitching about 28 days they got a
[ __ ] day they got a half a month and
a half a month they're the hardest
working people on the planet I see you
don't hear it I'm bitching the plane
about nothing so we have Cinco DeMayo in
one week of Hispanic awareness I'm like
it's just people said exactly everything
you said working freedom stood in a
quote while I delegated to 28 days what
are you giving me 28 days well
supposedly I think it's because it's
Frederick Douglass's birthday or
something so I don't know but this
should be said a little check or so to
know but also there's the I mean you're
right the the separating it out can be
problematic because history itself
American history itself is black history
black history is American history you
can't separate you can can't no it was
built on the back yes black Holocaust
it's all-encompassing together and the
reason like ice tell people like we live
in a black and white United States but
we live in a black and white world but
especially the United States is the
black and white world I said but then
who even came up with those colors like
nobody's black and nobody's white like
white is is this you know Plus and
everybody's everybody else is in those
two spectrums of colors I said so but
and only two people that [ __ ] and
complain about everything are white
people in black people you never hear
that the yellow people for the lack of a
better caller Hispanics and Asians or
get you about anything but you bump I
say is topi part of the top people of
color ISM color ISM you know I have a
joke about colorism you know they
whatever right and then some I'm leading
him upon Twitter
Philippians talk about colorism LeBlanc
whatever and I didn't explain it to her
she was cool [ __ ] but well it explain to
you exactly exponential but then she
said you know has anybody you know who
listen to that joke thought about having
a place to talk why they ever wanted to
talk and discuss it hell no sometimes
are you serious oh yeah people forget
that wouldn't up running for office
alright we're not trying to we're gonna
see how the world work on know what
you're not doing the TED talk you know
how it is man I did the brain probe last
week and I'm standing outside Chile they
have to get myself out of Thrones ego
you know what
people shouldn't complain to me man I
work at the mall to buy more I usually
improv right next to own AV still
complain on my show I work at the mall
because most of them are in malls yeah I
work at the mall be I talked to the
manager uli better right yeah yeah that
girl she had a she had some interesting
you so woke you can figure that out
what's the problem they don't right but
I don't think they understand this
younger generation doesn't understand
what comedy is and they haven't well you
can't do colleges normal right and they
haven't Sophie seen they haven't seen
the older comment it's like George
Carlin these other people Richard Pryor
that
make you think you're supposed to go
home and think about you know you know
what that was funny but like it's also a
deep Harley Carlin would get murder
today that man was alive dude oh yeah
yeah that's what Eddie Murphy he has a
bit on the n-word yeah I believe you
listen that [ __ ]
you know people can consider it racist
well it's not just breaking down what
that word is it's like I had to do to
prote me at the improv here in LA
approached me after the show he said cuz
I could I said the word [ __ ] and he got
all offended and I was like you know I
said I'm sorry and I sighs are you [ __ ]
and he was like no I was like oh I was
gonna apologize I meant no disrespect I
said you have gay friends he said no I
was like what the [ __ ]
it's beef that it's always people who
are not affected who want to be they
always want to have a voice yeah I said
what's a platform yeah what I feel like
hey I did something I stood up for
somebody today who never asked me to
stand up for them he was like well that
words really abrasive and offensive
what's a joke he has a joke about people
in wheelchairs right yeah but you've
actually had people in wheelchairs come
up to your love that joke they're so
happy for representation they have told
me you should do more jokes about
wheelchairs people might get offended
with who people who could walk throw
[ __ ] that enough tap-dance dogs there
hasn't been one person in a wheelchair
with everything matters ever been and
you know sometimes it's like even when I
look around the room and you say you do
like a if you got a fat person you know
oh I do I know but sometimes it's the
fat people that are laughing the heart
the skinny people are the ones offended
I'm like how can this obese woman be
dying over here
[ __ ] pissed like why yeah I don't I
don't get it man yeah I get it
like victims the other day I'm I would
be French somebody hello last night you
know um after my interview I give a seat
one of those drop cars I have him on my
album to this lady then after him I
remember I remember the cameraman with a
fan right I don't know his name I said
take the cameraman with a fan so which
one is the fat one then I walked away it
was time to give very much and I walked
away I thought the talking to my
publicist Veronica and say you know what
two years from now I'm gonna be able to
say that you know what the fat guy hmm
you know somebody's gonna cut me off and
tell me a man named it man you I said I
don't know his name man or to this but
you know right away who was talking
about the bad guy black guy or the
[ __ ] Asian guy who was a brilliant Oh
bro the guy over there bro the one okay
[ __ ] you wear a red t-shirt okay [ __ ] I
don't know bro he had [ __ ] ugly ass
hair yeah hair like [ __ ] moon he said
well now the other person we're playing
a game now we're playing [ __ ]
charades
when I could have just said it was a
[ __ ] Chinese guy but he goes they
know the guy was a [ __ ] I'm the
little guy man together 100 pounds the
guy that [ __ ] literally he had a
ninja star on him oh you talk about the
Asian guy yeah that's Luke okay [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] Luke shine you do you do
a lot of black room so right I used to
UM I I mean I you don't you didn't know
like I didn't know there was such a
thing as like urban or mainstream or
that you know you don't know it's been
divided your teeth yeah yeah so I you
know you don't know that in the
beginning especially like just from
watching TV you know there wasn't
anything out there other than Letterman
and you know Leno and Letterman yeah so
you had you know The Tonight Show The
Late shows and stuff like that so then
when Def Jam came on you know everybody
watches Def Jam I don't care who you
were white black Hispanic Asian every
was huge it was insane it changed it
changed comedy for the good at that
moment at that meal and they literally
were a voice for people to truly speak
out and say what everybody basically no
man like back there my little our white
Carmen as I said they were not funny but
they're any of the improv but enough
talk about burning toast I don't get I
can't laugh at burritos jobs or airplane
food yeah I want the hoodie joke you
talk about what too much
real or if you like I did I did the
Laugh Factory one when Jamie still had
it in New York
buddy Cabana weeks freaking I did I did
a [ __ ] joke and and the white host who I
had no idea who was like I had lined the
room and she I was done like I killed
the show and as you know everybody's
there white black Hispanic it's time
squared
get done have a unbelievable set selling
my CDs she says after I'm done she's
like oh my goodness like isn't he
supposed to be some famous comedian and
he does a [ __ ] joke
and I was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me like you're talking about me while
I'm still in the room and you're the
host I said so I now yell out of so well
you do some relationship jokes I said
you're brilliant like that's that's not
redundant that's never been done before
I'm surprised you don't have a sitcom
already you should have a TV show like
who hasn't done is a relationship joke
you're the first person ever to do it
so I'm like you know people you even got
comics that couldn't critique comedy T
comics and I'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding me like do we [ __ ] it's it's a
bodily function we do it like yeah when
you're not when you're not funny or
successful or on a TV show you become a
comedy blogger and that's how you do
this [ __ ] on good comedy because you
[ __ ] suck but you've never told one
joke there - one funny joke somebody can
be funnier you know what somebody's
lacking you know why somebody sucks and
and that's what like people who like
there was somebody who was going to like
a comedy class like I'm like there's no
there's no rhyme or reason to this
there's you know you because people
always ask me for advice that's the only
advice I can give you now if you're if
you're an up-and-coming comic is try to
become Internet an internet sensation
overnight like some of these people are
doing I said because now age our comedy
clubs don't ask your agent whoa what was
his credits how many followers does he
have so that's the first thing they ask
what's your following I deleted in my
social media years ago I literally just
got back on it so people are like I was
in in Whole Foods in El Segundo with my
daughter the other day yesterday as a
matter of fact some dudes like comedian
I see yeah he's like great ray Lipowski
I said yeah so I'm with my daughter and
I hate being with my one one of my
daughters because these people look like
I'm like you know the sugar daddy with
I'm like it's my [ __ ] kid like stop
looking at us like that how old is she
24 oh yeah because he's like I aren't
you like 35 how the [ __ ] is she 20
forever when she was 11 when you were 11
I said no bro she's like he's like 55
let say a relaxed I'm giving me some
extra years oh you had her when you're
19 20 29 29 I'll be 53 in December
I know welcome with my daughter I look
like a [ __ ] Arab guy who just got a
girl and then what would Lisa were
high-fiving me got you white one do I do
that man like you would date a black
woman my wife married oh yeah when did
you ever get [ __ ] from people did she
get [ __ ] from people or no we did all
the time so his friends huh especially
where I'm from because I'm from the west
side of Chicago then I grew up in Cicero
Illinois right when I juice a row when I
grew up in Cicero was all it was it was
ran by the Mafia it was I grew up with
that is where I moved into took over the
top next to school be anyone they read
that was their home front that because
he got tired of paying I hate everything
because it was a small little town it
was the first town outside of Chicago
ten minutes from Cicero to downtown
Chicago at a Roman name I love it you
had three you had three major streets
Cicero Avenue halls
I mean Roosevelt and uh Cermak then you
had two major highways 55 and 290 going
in and out of Chicago you had to train
so it made sense the set up shop or Al
Capone did so I mean nothing lot Messier
there's no cheese shuttle yeah it's like
nine it's like 90 97 percent I did a
show there back in the days and there
was a family in Cicero that we won't
know we went to her house and as all the
rock Mexican you know the kids were born
there so that that was born in Mexico
and they have a snow employment business
I don't during the there is no normal
summer they cut trees and it's all wood
and you know they pretty much do
whatever they could do but in the summer
in the winter
those foods were the first guys to have
like a snow plow in their Montecarlo or
whatever or in a truck and they were
providing snow plot for the hood
they don't laugh nobody does that for
the hood so they were doing it for the
hood taxing fools but man they made us
uh they made us a soup with meat and we
put cheese in in and they made homemade
tortilla for us and I love your youngest
kid who like 17 or 18 I put smoke me out
oh and the guy were aware that food
maybe them quesadillas yeah but that's
where you from man yeah what's it like
growing up there man I mean most people
to be nice huh it was cool when you like
when you look at it now though like you
don't realize is when your kid how
racist it is and all of that stuff your
your kid so you you go with what you
know you know you grow up only around
white white white kids I didn't know
none of these kids that I grew up with
their dads were made mobsters until I
got older like literally made mobsters
like in order to be a made mob so you
have to be 100% of talent so you know
seeing us and and seeing these kids dads
or you know in jail now for the rest of
their lives and I was like damn so you
know again looking back like when people
say that they're a product of their
environment I say I beg to differ
because if that's the case where I'm
from I'm supposed to hate black people
and I married a black woman 25 years ago
so I said it's you know like people that
whole color thing to know like we always
got looks everywhere we went I was like
it's this is [ __ ] nuts man just
because I'm like if you're miserable in
life like people want to take out you
know their misery it Aysen want you to
be miserable as well I'm like this is
[ __ ] crazy about that on stage and
I'm like you you had like I don't want
people to think like you know because
when some peeps sometimes people compare
me to Gary Owens and no disrespect to
Gary Owens whatsoever I'm like the word
totally on totally different comics but
the only comment is we were you know
Gary's been married to I don't know how
long he's been with his wife now I know
10 plus years but I'm like a 25 years
because then people think like this
black woman married me all the jungle
fever or oh he's just comic on TV so she
married us yeah because he's you know
he's about to be you know some big comic
I was like no she married me before I
didn't even do comedy then and she when
I told her I was doing comedy she was
like you're not even funny I was like
you know gee thanks I thanks for the
support like me
provide us with our money see you're not
even funny like are you [ __ ] kidding
me and then I remember the first time I
got my first gig we were in our in our
driveway at the house and someone called
me from comic view from BT and I thought
it was somebody playing around and
they're like you know hey ray like he
likes Lisa you know from BT I'm trying
to book you know I'm look for ray
Lipowski when a booking for comic view
and I was like shut the [ __ ] up like who
is this
and she's like excuse me and I was like
oh oh I'm so sorry this is this really
comic music I'm like how did you get my
number
damn my first comic yo did in Miami at
the Jackie Gleason theatres April 1st
April Fool's joke bro apologies on a
plane with Marilyn Martinez and joy
Medina and they called a big bambam bro
on the plane they call up Ernie G and
they said hey man this is um Jim
top-ranked - Jim Clements from the
Letterman Show and somehow we got ahold
of your video
can you please call those that - one -
was he calling you guys I trying to get
the number one best break ever
how about that one time I got til
chompy's at the ice house when rick
atheras first moved to LA joy Medina
maybe was joy Medina wrong so every diva
and Willie Willie Barcena they crack
calm hey man we're uh which was just
caught your tape again and now we're
thinking of having a development meaning
I can just meet at the ice house around
2:00 p.m. and we'll have over there the
foot takes a shower bro light ever
cigarette he don't have cigarette breath
and he gets here bro just a notice her
loser or welcome to our lair something
like that dude that whatever new man
you hear some funny stories about
somebody's like big-name comics like
like dude just some funny [ __ ] like that
or even like sending just like chicks
the rooms and stuff like that but it'll
be like some like overly obese chick or
something that they pay to come to
somebody's room and now you know like
what are you doing here you know dancing
all of it - so you just hear funny story
that's just hilarious though a dude
those towns are still kind of corrupt
over there like Cicero Melrose Park and
all those places yeah definitely cuz I
heard a dude that lived next my
grandparents lived there but anyways
like we opened up a business they'll
give you the license but then like a
doodle come in a you know fire
sprinklers from us yeah you gotta get
everything ever every code and ordinance
Cicero has its own to show you how
corrupt that town was Betty Lauren
Maltese whose husband was a maid mobster
she was the town president because we
it's not this it's a Township yes yes
town president and she was living in
Vegas while running running
Cicero Washington then she went to jail
living in Vegas she went to jail for
like eight years because of all that
racketeering and all that stuff they
payouts and it's funny supposedly to
like when Obama was running that's one
thing they never mentioned he came from
a corrupt ass state and then that Rob
Blagojevich got busted trying to sell a
seat yeah that guy there was a guy that
I'm now working in Vegas we impress he
punch acog oh and he told me that wow
the bigger monster Chicago never got
arrested he's still alive life he led
Sam Giancana get all the press who was
his name was Tony batts
Tony Accardo Tony Accardo and that full
star he's out that fool was part he was
read more about him he was he was one of
the killers at the biggest the
Valentine's Day Massacre
I met my dad one of my dad's best
friends you said wasn't one of the
drivers for Capone and after Lou said
that he started it up he was taxed you
know a bunch of whorehouses in Chicago
Al Capone had won like four blocks from
my house in Cicero and then later on 80s
when [ __ ] was changing that Tony bats
made that made it an escort a legitimate
escort service there was there was at
least
three three four houses in Cicero and
there was the one that in Capone's day
it was like a club restaurant all that
stuff in a brothel all in one and a lady
who was the madam
she lived there until she passed away
and I wanted to go in that house so bad
I want cuz I might just gotta be some
[ __ ] in here yeah like he's gotta have
some very true and then he just knocked
that place down but and she had like a
million catch it like over 100 cats he
was collared cat lady it was [ __ ]
weird when that bull 20 bats never been
arrested either welcome Tony Accardo I
went to school with his with his
granddaughter what was this a test not
getting caught those old mobsters they
were talking the floor yeah he was never
in a group yeah you're running it
running run every they say he was the
head of all that the other indicate yeah
they're not just not just of Chicago of
all of it because that's a Giancana back
in the day too was like that too he was
the head not like anyone from New York
that that Sam was the man like he was
head of everything he was he was dating
one of them were greater sisters right
one of the singers I don't know though
these three singers they were twins
triplets and they were I don't know do
with any one of them I know but Sam Sam
like a little bit of the limelight I
think yeah they say you know Sam she
kind of look cool though bro no you got
that nice suit yeah and the slick black
hair and then the rim black glasses and
they say he would like you know just
like try to date Hollywood starlets and
stuff like that and and the one that was
getting pursued by a robert f kennedy
right i think yeah one of yeah somebody
yes sister was nuts man but again you
didn't know that as a kid like you know
you knew everybody on the block knew you
you could be disciplined by somebody on
the block you know somebody's always
good like now try to say something to
some kid like a hey you got a [ __ ]
street kid you're about to get hit yeah
don't tell my kid who the [ __ ] are you
to talk to you okay let this [ __ ]
idiot get hit then like are you kidding
me I'm trying to help your kid out where
did the Irish live over there in in
Chicago Chicago
there's no like no no it was no clumps
of like even though like how sis I mean
Chicago is so segregated but in Cicero
there was no segregation it was
everybody just you know it probably was
there was no ethnics no no yeah no black
people wouldn't even come I always stuck
to the south side yeah black people
would not the only time they would ever
come to Cicero would go to go to
sportsmen racetrack and then I had
buddies because you said to go to
sportsmen racetrack you would have to
come from Chicago and you take Cicero
Avenue so once you got the sister Avenue
you would turn down what's at 31st and
you would make the left and you'd have
to go under this Vidak and when you
would have to go under the viaduct I
would have buddies that would sit up on
the viaduct and and it when they would
see a car coming so as a black idea
would throw rocks at their karma quite a
[ __ ] do you do that and they're like
[ __ ] these n words and I was like dude
like I ain't bothering you like the
Bronx - yeah that's literally what it
was like like so I was like but they're
not bothering you ain't doing them and
no how would you feel somebody throwing
rocks at your dad's car like what the
[ __ ] up so I wouldn't do [ __ ] like that
so but you know you you're you you get
ingrained with certain things and then
at the same time you either cuz I think
I don't care what anybody says I think
racism starts at home like if you got
parents that you know are like that I'm
like my parents never talked about stuff
like that I mean did they ever say the
n-word of stuff oh I'm sure they did but
it wasn't like but I'm not gonna say it
wasn't with hatred or it was with hatred
I don't know but I love like man that
yeah
like he liked talking about Jordan and
n-word can really jump like if he
amazing like I loved you I put him and
we had I did a podcast with a movie
podcast because we did a we did a show
we saw that movie the hateful eight
hateful eight right the cup the cowboy
movie Tarantino what church you know one
yeah and all the name of the guy with
the pod can we had him on a show Oh join
Perkins Twain port okay yeah so so they
took the n-word like more time than ever
heard right
Stiles is right that's clean Tarantino
so what's it like to be in again so
doing that Duane I Perkins we had a game
when we saw that movie it'll be called
how many times they said the n-word in a
positive way
it was it was a saver
saved up retire why the first time I
came out here and I hid my car out here
one night yes so I took the 210 I don't
know somebody asked me to come due to
like The Laugh Factory at a comedy store
so I take the 210 and all that's though
and I'm like I I had never heard the
n-word said so many times my best kids
no buy black he said this and every
other word was like my n-word you know
you know I'm saying my n-word my n-word
I was like oh yeah I wanted to stop and
be like dude how many [ __ ] times are
you gonna call this dude and reference
your buddy is the n-word like you okay
you know what I'm saying my n-word and
then he states that my n-word I was like
oh my goodness I need to make my [ __ ]
ears hurt that's a dude like shut the
[ __ ] up already
did Jordan help out race relations at
all on Chicago you know what it's weird
because I would even say just like about
my dad like my dad would say racist
things not even realizing I'm think he's
saying I'm gonna be like yeah black
people love chicken or watermelon I'm
like you like chicken watermelon
the [ __ ] are you saying like are we
black the head like [ __ ] chicken I
love the old poor local buy me on
Crenshaw and um and artesia is the best
up or your local I think those dudes in
there seasoned it themselves like yes
like they like we're gonna do with the
way we want it because I hate when
people say something like is like like
Chipotle or something's not authentic
Mexican well of course it's not but then
what is authentic Mexican I'm like all
Mexicans are in there making it they're
all working in there so it's really just
beans and meat and rice there it's all
funny to me oh good boy we don't you cog
O'Toole man awesome most burrito Chicago
and famous burrito think El famous
Chicago in my opinion they couldn't have
that's Mexican food on the planet I've
not found good Mexican food you know the
right people there's a my sister used to
live in this in a in it I know it's like
right outside of downtown Chicago and
it's one block it's an Italian block
there's six restaurants six Italian
restaurants on one block it's called
who's rivers right no you use it you
portly boy locos that one
by me I'm telling you Crenshaw and
artesia the best El Pollo Loco there is
that dude seasons it himself
but my sister so outside of that one
block it's called Little Italy it was
all Hispanics moving over there so rude
and when I would go to Chicago I would
stay with it so I don't have to you know
get in a hotel and stuff like that so
there's always this Mexican dude Javier
he'll be pushing that car to be like
6:30 in the morning I'm sleeping in a
living room on her couch no he'll be
like Ross bajas frutas a latte is
ringing that [ __ ] Bell and I'm like
dude it's [ __ ] 6:30 in the morning
who's eating it [ __ ] at 6:30 in the
morning I'm like nah let me up let me
get one in corn it's like yeah let me
get one let me load this put that put
that mayonnaise on there with that
orange that sprinkled [ __ ] you put on
let me get one oh that 6:30 in the
morning I'm eating this yeah wonder why
I'm high cholesterol who have yet is a G
Javier somebody was listening life said
Javier is a G of doing that for doing
that yeah yeah boy you're seasoning
myself it might be Javier I don't know
but he is that's the only point look at
it I mean uh for our favorite burrito
right now Chicago and then there's a
place on Cicero in Cicero called mr.
taco it's on Ogden Avenue in Austin it's
been there for like [ __ ] 40 years I
when I went back I had a maybe six
months ago that place is exactly the
same they've not changed anything in it
and a makeup killing and that that
burrito tasted exactly like I remember
when I was a kid I was like pizza
casserole no you're gonna get real deep
dish pizza you got to go to Paisano's on
State Street in Chicago yeah it's more
touristy but Paisano's is authentic
uno is is definitely authentic hands
the best but no yeah you gotta go and
then Portillo's but there's a Portillo's
out here so where oh yeah boy in a park
in a park where no Valley has one yeah
you gotta go to fourth you ain't had
Portillo's bro I did a long time ago car
hot dogs and [ __ ] oh yeah oh we're at
riddles yeah man those were the days
when we should do that do we how many
people were in that show already know
tell me put on the show five dude it was
me I did morning on Riggle charreteras
Felipe who else Joey Diaz and him yeah
enjoy beer Gomez no I don't know the
speaker
Oh Alex Ortiz another sort yeah I missed
those riddled days man
yes Ari Shaffir that's right yes yeah
what's a thot you gave me the Bravo 16
kids amazing do or die ha ha
so uh would you prefer man Cubs or White
Sox White Sox yeah you know would you
ever go to a Cubs game I've gone to Cubs
me cuz I won't tell my when I was in
Chicago the chat my co-chair gave me
some socks tickets and therefore jovial
go makes Blakeley said I ain't going
without me anybody are you gonna fight
them off she we were to a Sox game right
back you know that we know one of the
trainer guys now ok he's a fan I got to
meet Harold Baines okay he gave her an
autographed ball oh my god that's one of
the cool things too that was fun like we
don't know who knows us and that's like
one of the cool things that comes with
it like when you get somebody who's
famous and it's you're a fan of and then
not even realizing like they're a fan of
as well you like you even know who I am
like like Derrick Rose when he was
Derrick Rose MVP Derrick Rose he was
like he would always wanted me to hang
with him and I'm like Derrick Rose let's
both know whoever's shooting my house he
would he would hit me up and be like you
know what are you doing I'm like did you
kick it with that foot oh yeah all the
time he's hanging with him he's gonna go
to the clubs with him all the time I'm
gonna kick it with you yeah all the time
all the time I was like cuz when I met
him I met him at the I was doing Martin
Lawrence's first-amendment we were doing
at the Chicago theater and you've done
in Chicago theater yeah you know how you
go in for the entrance for the for the
entertainment one and all the trucks and
what an hour set up on the side like
it's an alley but it's not an alley so I
was you know getting ready to go in and
Derrick was on the side over there and
he was calling me and I was like you
know here's somebody saying race so I
look and I hit see it's Derrick Rose and
I'm like he's not calling me Ray's like
must be some rare a Lewis thank you yeah
so I walked over to my like hey dude you
know who I am he was like yeah you're
one of my favorite comedians I said Wow
cool
same thing with Evan Turner plays for
now - Portland Trailblazers he was
honest he wasn't even out in the Sixers
he wasn't drafted yet I was in downtown
Chicago on Michigan Avenue I was on the
west side of Michigan Avenue he was on
east side and I hear some black dude
screaming my name and I'm like who the
[ __ ] is this big-ass black dude
screaming my name so as he's walking
across the street I'm like okay I know
this dude but I don't know his name and
then as he's getting closer and closer I
said damn it's Evan Turner that's where
right when he just left Ohio State he
was the Naismith College Player of the
Year and I was like hey damn you're Evan
Turner and he's like yeah like you're
ray lapowski and I was like yeah so I
said you know who I am and same thing he
said almost the same thing verbatim like
Rose said he's like yeah you're one of
my favorite comedians I watch you all
the time when I'm having a bad day
that's it bro but you ever get somebody
saying something yes do you like hair
you Felipe Esparza and you'd be like
yeah be like no you're not [ __ ]
like say are you Reina posture yeah he's
like no you're not so you're right I'm
nice I guess you are I'm like okay make
up my mind am i me or my not me like are
you [ __ ] kidding me and then when
Dane Cook was big I'm on this plane I
got the aisle seat I got two young white
kids like maybe 12 and 13 middle and and
windows Sifu fire
so he's I did yeah they're looking at me
and they're like this kept staring him
and I said you guys want to say
something to me they're like is your
name ray Lipowski and I said yeah
they're like do you know Dane Cook I
said get the [ __ ] out why you don't care
about me Turk the dog Rose ever asked
you to hold his crutches but he gets in
the car no no I talked him ever since
like he had the big blowout like he went
into like seclusion and you know I don't
know like he was always he's was this
aloof and you know he was like he was
like my private do with the exception of
I mean he went out there clubs from time
to time but you know family definitely
family orientated man you know loves his
family and whatnot but after he blew out
his knee I text them a few days after
and I was like hey bro like you know
keep you my prayers
you know so what a hangout you want to
go to gloves look for some [ __ ] no no
I am I never heard from him again so you
know a solid month of family loves you
by the way monka for a worse mess was a
lake man you work with dude a raven yeah
a lot of people you open I open up a lot
of people to man like Russell Peters
[ __ ] Paul Rodriguez was it like one
the roley's get you started with these
guys huh well yeah I've been working
with you Ray for like you know not that
I've been working with him but I mean
I've known DeRay for 19 years and you
know sometimes comics can fall into
where I think I'm kind of at where you
fall into a place where some big-name
comics don't want to use you like I'm
there's got to be some big-name comics
that don't want to use you not because
they don't like you because you're too
funny and you're gonna make them have to
really work or struggle to come after
you they'll give me five yeah yeah then
go hit them with that quick five what is
that right what can you really do yeah
what are you really doing coke you quit
five yeah yeah
you know Corey Holcomb of course yeah so
but yeah there's no you know comics but
when you get somebody like dear a who
who you know looks out for my gaps but
do you work dear a always my cups too
they always like a strong scrunch or
like strong you like somebody they know
is gonna kill who is who could do it our
and there's not a lot of comics like
this because then they feel like for
dear a great that I'm gonna speak who
doing our work because I'm gonna be late
[Laughter]
you know I had to do that for and I was
pissed you know for [ __ ] Aries Spears
that he doesn't speak to nobody he
doesn't say [ __ ] we did a college I want
to say was like Wake Forest University I
did I was only supposed to do 30 it was
only me and him well we're there was a
woman who booked us female comedian
she's from out there like in a North
Carolina way I could I think wake forces
in North Carolina so she hosted it
Deborah Terry she did like 10 minutes I
had to do 30 and then re supposed to do
like his 45 to 50 I do my 30 are we
still not there so she's like ray you
know can you do like another 15 so I do
to 15 hours and I'm at 45
she's like ray I don't think he's coming
so she's just keep going I had to do
another 45 I've been hour and a half now
he finally comes and he acts like it's
no big deal and cuz she wasn't gonna pay
him and then he ends up going up he
didn't say a word to me didn't speak to
me and say hey like thanks then say [ __ ]
Wow didn't even didn't even speak to me
and I was like so when you see people
I'm never gonna speak ill or bad about
anybody but I look at it as when you see
people who are funny that are going
through some things that they that
they're going through and I'm thinking
like what what are you really going
through because there's a lot of people
a lot of comics that would love to have
the the livelihood that you have and and
be booked at the amount of times it's
your book cuz I tell people all the time
like when you're having a bad day you
stop and ask yourself compared to who
who you having a bad day it's compared
to Nick you're a bro so so much bye
Willie
my little Sam yeah so you know some some
comics I think like you know if you
don't respect the game the games not
going to respect you eventually there's
there's there's some money I'm not going
to say his name it caught up to em - I
did one night showing in at the Fort
Lauderdale improv or whatever it is I
got a one-nighter Thursday and it's the
10:30 show he's booked for the weekend
his show is at 8 o'clock just that he's
got the one show Thursday and then the
Friday Saturday Sunday he does he
doesn't he's over now a half hour he's
over the managers lighten them he looks
at the manager says I see the light I'm
not getting off [ __ ] that light okay the
lines my show sold out 500 people so
look it's one of the bigger improv so
low we're like what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude so now the host for my show
is like lighting them to nothing he
ended up doing like 2 hours and 15
minutes when there's a show after this
show after this show packed might know
he'll know it was like it was like half
was a Thursday night it was expressing
himself so here let's just say he then
comes a half after the show says man for
again my fault you guys I did I was I
was in our conscious at a time we're
like how can you possibly say yeah you
said after light you see the light
you're not getting off but if you're not
you weren't conscious of the time and
now I was thinking to myself this is
exactly why you don't have your TV show
no more because of [ __ ] just like that
because you think you're bigger than you
are now and you don't respect the game
and or the comics that are trying to get
to the level that you're at like when
you start [ __ ] out comics and
[ __ ] on the game and acting like
you're bigger than comedy itself you
keep that [ __ ] to yourself yeah yeah at
least keep it myself what do you say
again for listeners thanks he said [ __ ]
that way I'm not getting second yeah I
see the light I'm not going off I see
the light this is the manager lighting
you I see the light
looking direct I see the like I'm not
getting off [ __ ] that light and then
proceeded to do and
least another 45 is micro after that I
kept tell much you got a fool enough I
would I said I would at that show for
that 500 for that show that was sold out
for my show I want to say probably like
a hundred and twenty people left because
it was so late into Thursday night
people got to work it's already 10:30 my
show didn't start - almost like probably
like midnight when it should be ending
at midnight I was a manager I have some
somebody walk up there and put him to
sleep er well there was a younger or
newer comic years ago at the Laugh
Factory I remember he was bombing on
Latino night he was bombing after like
five Abu 2020 he was bombing after five
Jaime himself he walked in there it's
like who the [ __ ] is this he sucks
he went he's flashing hand along here
it's long here now anyway he was
flashing him over and over and over he
didn't get off he did the 20 he finally
gets off Jaime said what's wrong with
you why didn't you get off and Mika was
standing there - why didn't you get off
I wasn't done yet I didn't finish my 20
the owner I met you you get the [ __ ] off
the stage all right never he never
performed there again like this far I
had the mayor of Chicago Heights take me
off the stage I had douche I had to do a
show for these old white people all it
will old white people that were retired
workers for the town of Chicago Heights
so when I got there you know a little
hundred dollar gig and it was like five
minutes from my house so again all these
old white people retired so I'm sort of
just hosted so I'm hosting it like my
first 10 minutes I'm killing him and
then all of a sudden I just paused and
when I pause some old lady's probably
like about 80 she's like you know what
are you doing I said what do you mean so
I'm taking a break
she's like why and I was like what the
hell so then I forget what she said in
the dialogue that we had but this is the
part I remember she's like well you're
not funny right now you're not your lady
do and I said lady doesn't matter if I'm
funny she's like what do you mean so she
says
it was so she says what do you mean it
doesn't matter I said because half of
you in here's got Alzheimer's I said I
give you the funniest comment you ever
seen or the worse you ever seen by
tomorrow you're gonna remember this [ __ ]
anyway
man that mayor was like no he didn't
come up yet that's not what pissed him
off so then I talked about how when I
was a kid sister Cicero didn't have
Cicero didn't have no garbage disposal
pick up where you had to pay for it it
was garbage service now you got managed
ya waste man you got to pay for that
[ __ ]
so I said who came up with this covered
who came up with the scam for this
[ __ ] waste management [ __ ] it was his
parents that owned the business so he
came a hidden agent and and literally
like took me Hollywood's the stories you
gotta have doing as much as you're on
the road dude with somebody's funny or
his dude your way you gotta have stories
for days triple G or Canelo I'm going
with triple G triple G you go triple G
I'm going last fight at the hey some
tacos in Mexico and he said they were
laced with steroids I was excused yes or
no he went he went to the apoyo local by
me Shivaji Rodrigo triple G Canelo
Colorado what's up fool upcoming shows
Atlantic City New Jersey September 7 at
the Borgata watch this behind in
September 8 that's right that's this
Saturday at the National Harbor Casino
Las Vegas September 14 at the joint at
the Hard Rock Casino and you're gonna be
at the weigh-in that day too
yeah would you go play with yourself
after Laughlin September 15 at Edgewater
casino Lexington Kentucky September 20th
to the 22nd and comedy off Broadway
Springfield Massachusetts at temperature
89 at City stage Symphony Hall
check out Philippa WorldCom's last tour
for our upcoming shows
podcast teachers are on sale now at the
Philebus world.com shop we also have
bag that's right tote bags for those who
care about the environment we have tote
bags for you to go grocery shopping with
they only cost five bucks also you can
also buy the digital download and
translate this on my webpage to
sheriff's or for people who bought the
album this week the vinyl shows
yeah be with DeRay this weekend in
Richmond
yeah Richmond we're at Richmond weekend
yeah
Richmond Virginia at the at the funny
bone at the Richmond Virginia so those
funny bond over there that's isn't his
area isn't that his market over there
dc-dc like 1dc then like Ren shows or 11
we do that like that's crazy
did they just keep adding on once you
were there or do they add him before he
even got some of them have the same
agent some of them are before but yeah
like these are the two shows Thursday
once a Thursday I want to say Thursday
we didn't one but we just like we did
make three every other night we did
Nebraska but we did we stopped in
Nebraska we did Omaha he did he did two
sold-out shows on a Thursday because it
was already booked for the weekend but
whoever the comedian was there that was
there for the weekend he didn't do the
Thursday so being it we were going to
Kansas City we stopped it did Omaha and
he did the two sold-out shows for a
Thursday which is big because I I've not
seen many comics you know sellout
Thursday's me the two sold-out Thursday
shows and then we went Omaha and then we
did Friday
how about Toby what was it like to do 11
shows oh that's crazy it's tiring so the
three shows Sunday you did a 30 minutes
reply yeah I got I got to do 30 cuz it
was just me and him so my leg when it's
just when it's just me and him just you
have no opener no yeah I saw March know
he used to we don't I don't know why
don't you do yeah so much so CD why I
saw I saw I saw scratch on a plane hit a
middle seat next to me and so and then
he was telling her he was talking about
the shows then I thought after Carol I
heard those enough and a big whap of
money
I'm off with pocket and I picked it up
and I said man your money it's come on
stove he said ah
DVD Mali because a mattress money
mattress buddy but he saw a shitload of
DVDs or CDs a rages I sold everything
some comics news they say Michael
Collier sells like crazy
it's like dollars those hats right babes
I don't know but III it's crazy day and
for keeps
I don't know but they say the amount of
money that he makes it in merch sales
like insane what sofa what's your
Instagram since you have an Instagram
now comedian lapowski comedian lip li p
o WS ki comedian Lipowski is just my
last name so comedian in front of it in
my last name and and man I truly
appreciate it been a fan of yours bro
you love you and I wish you both of you
guys thank you continued success and all
you do and aspire to do man love you man
which I love you too man we try to get
up DeRay Davis to call in okay and bust
your balls but I can get to the busy man
yeah one of us it must have responded
okay look a dog yeah shoutouts to Rickey
a tricky in 207 on Twitter came out to
the Brad shows as for shout out and
Jenna at Chen stupid on Twitter
congratulations on your five year
anniversary with your boyfriend shout
out to Raleigh fingers man oh alright
starstruck bro you take a picture do a
picture bro and I stalk them do you
think he's like Joe Namath does he still
get up with girls and stuff there with
wife and his son the family got it and
he was no name is still banging chicks
well did you get busted for grabbing
that one girl by the cheese go
I don't like that generation think you
just grabbed I really kissed a bro like
pasta with a cable like in a white sock
patty
there's no kissing booth in Cicero yeah
you can't do it overnight I remember
guys just like every time meeting a
woman is kissing on bro and you remember
that one my dad you were gone though
dude you took off but when he laughs
again ah dude [ __ ] a big dog made out
with a 70 year old lady from the stage I
was talking about last night for it was
the old old she was older than Debbie
she was like 78 and then he came back
the next day she come back the next day
all dressed up no that's another one but
she wasn't it that lady came back wasn't
his older we're talking about that one
so how old is he your age no born in 62
or 66 years but how old is he really at
the time when I had those is what was
telling me I was a stroll out bro she
must have been a friend a prison or
something dude she was waiting like
almost like chance bro like total shorts
and long socks and I would like a
Pendleton bro well yeah but you said
that was like disgusting Tudor like
wouldn't kissing [ __ ] I'm wondering
now like when I could was kissing this
like 24 year old if like her friends
were thinking like that everybody's
patron but oh just Cuervo patron bro he
was gone
that's not Anthony Mason was he used to
play for the next he knew like he knew
if it wasn't patron like because he only
drank patron the guy he knew he'd wear
bro right when you bring her you'll
smell oh that's the only thing he would
drink he would he would make you drink
and few didn't drink he like punch you
in the chest dude you're like six nine
three hundred pounds so I'm not the
owner of a tip a yacht bro Manny write a
samosa first basketball player I
remember who had those huge deltoids you
know that just Johnny I was amazing
player that'd be a good three heads to
Lisa the snow queen people what who ray
lapowski get out here go say what's up
with him after you were derail then were
you right after that just wouldn't I've
just been on the road him so I've left
the dates you know just some readily
accessible to do the host dates oh yeah
it's easy no pressure
yeah it makes it to where ever you know
again like if I have my own gigs though
and I don't want to be to where I'm not
available and then he'll be like oh he
can't do it
get somebody else rotation I have all my
gigs
Ari Shaffir
oh no Mike canceled on Rogan and then he
took Ari Shaffir then you know they spun
their relationship yeah I saw Joe and
airport one time and I'm not you know
I'm not a groupie of any kind but his
brother yeah but you see you see you're
okay you're Joe Rogan bro
but you know you see Joe Rogan in the
airport so I was like you know hey you
know and he's trying to be inconspicuous
now that's the capital with kettlebell I
said to try to like please food oh yeah
I know I didn't do the whole like oh I'm
a comedian too I so I was just we got a
mutual friend he's like oh do we like
bleep it who's that I don't know you
like that
so I said and so then that definitely
it's like you know he's trying to get
away from me so I said re he kind of
like sizing I said well yeah I used to
work with Ari a lot in Chicago I said
you know back in the riddle comedy club
days I said you know me and I used to
work together a lot and as well as Joey
Diaz so then when I've just started then
he like now he's you realize you're on a
stalker yeah and and and the fact that I
think that he respected that I didn't
have to tell him I was a comic I just by
the fact that I said we got a mutual
friend and I said you know we should
work together a lot in Chicago then
obviously he puts two and two together
oh he's a comic too and he was cool I
mean it was quick but he was cool like
who else did I mean Airport no what's
his name from jackass Johnny Knoxville
he didn't wanna you couldn't be trying
to speak he did he don't want to talk in
front we were waiting for Roscoe's we
were at Roscoe's chicken and waffles
when I was a tourist here with my like
the third time look at those deltoids no
no no he's talking he knew his skinny
dude but he you know me but he was
trying so hard to get noticed and I was
not giving them any time of day and my
friend wasn't she was ignoring him too
or we're all waiting outside in front of
Roscoe's like different pockets yes
that's when I met the young the wheel
tribe Lea tribe and we took a picture
with them and all this stuff that guy
over there I know he wants everybody to
come over to him but I'm more interested
in these guys anyhow pants all high kind
of look all hips but now that's weird
though because when I saw him and he was
with his wife I'm assuming his wife and
his kids he wasn't nobody was even
speaking like he that wasn't look he
wasn't like he was looking for attention
but it
same time there was nobody going up to
Johnny night I feel like and I was like
he just came off that movie
I forget what movie hazard ringer the
ringer maybe one of those he just came
off of a movie so it wasn't like it's
not he's not relevant that means not
he's not jackass relevant no more but I
mean still it's Johnny Knoxville it's a
body of work it's not what you just did
yesterday but nobody was saying nothing
to him I was shocked so I was thinking
like you you should be one to speak to
me research on a poison um Ethan Hogg at
a restaurant I did try to poison he was
a jerk to me but Gwyneth Paltrow was
very sweet I love her she got nice
deltoids wait
not going to the Paltrow what's-her-face
sorry oh nevermind wrong white blonde
girl you know everything okay but she
would they were still together at the
time you know the one moment no I don't
like is that Cherise the run or whatever
monster at least I don't like her
sure yeah I don't like her just because
it's the way she was to go Skokie today
is she from scope nut you know that what
those two twins that had the TV show
back in the day the Olsen twins know
that the Maori sisters are oh yeah
tomorrow yeah tomorrow tomorrow was they
work out at the same gym like same
Equinox or what now whatever it was and
whichever one it was she didn't even
wasn't even bother none of that type of
stuff she was just like you know like
like saying like you know I appreciate
you guys you know love your work like
basically all she was saying the twin
said that too yeah one of the Twin
Cities yet to Charlize yeah and she uh
she had to manage her comments that she
can if she's ever in here I'll never
come here again I'll never work out here
again I was like you know no to manager
Wow you keep hitting that plug yeah but
she yeah she went off like like this she
was bothering me and like
she's like no all I did was like say hey
I love you love you love what you do
like that's it like really I don't write
when you either super quick and simple
to the point like hey love what you guys
do and I'm out like say I'm mad after I
meet them
I'm at their show and after the show I
see them because they're getting ready
to leave and I'm hey great show love you
guys man and I'm out the door
damn and that's like all she did and
sure and the Tehran lady was like no
like if she ever if she ever comes here
again or if you guys allow her still to
retain her membership or wonder now I I
will take my I will quit like I'll I
won't have mine so that's right that's
why my point is like some of these
people like who - who the [ __ ] do you
think you are Ethan story cuz he comes
in he he came lumo was there with her
like niece or something they had dinner
this was Bobby Flay's restaurant Mesa
Grill in New York City when Bobby was
hot it had Grillin and chillin show and
all those Food Network shows so it's a
nicer rest to the moon robot he did the
running man he's a dork but so anyway
they're having dinner they had dinner
they were so nice and the nice is like
oh it's coming it's like she was excited
and I said okay whatever he shows up
after the kitchen closes kitchens closed
the chefs these are chefs they're not
lying cooks or anything they're gone he
comes in and he wants something to eat
and I said sorry the kitchen's been
closed for like half an hour
well Lisa because they had an open
kitchen like you could see in a big
picture window because that's the
attraction there you can watch everybody
cook in there he goes well you know you
could maybe you can go down there whip
me up some nachos or some first of all
we don't sell [ __ ] nachos nachos he
goes to me maybe you could go with me up
some nachos anyway he was just really
insistent that I go make him something
and I said I can't and I said you know
what there's a coffee shop bar where all
the models work right around the corner
there in the union square you can go
over there it's open 24 hours and um I
was like yeah you know what we can just
there's a lot to play
as we can go it's fine let's just go it
she was trying to urge him to get out he
was a dick he was like come on Lisi you
could I know what you could do something
whip me up something just an [ __ ]
just like he thinks he's somebody you
know [ __ ] okay that's it what so fool
well do you scare the ocean one time we
were here we were packing a ball outside
after outside Thrifty's or the [ __ ]
CBS
sunset and La Brea bro you know son said
all about the common sport yeah SUV SUV
windows went down the Thames to win of
the same time we're gonna fight up a cab
oh man 21 years old what's up fool take
very much to ray lapowski check him out
with deray davis and all his shows Lisa
I'm here Rodrigo Torres check him out at
Billy Loes jokes
September 11th yeah man